all right so it's ocean oroshi
how do i press your name ocean or Oceana
Oceana like the ocean
yes guys oh yeah what do you like better
ocean routes they're both you over oh
she calls me ocean but my clothing lines
called Oceana banana oh I see it's a
clothing line well my name is Oceana
so my clothing line is Oceana banana oh
by Oceania Pete I'm going on I'm going
with ocean it's not lit all right Oceana
Oceana uh where'd you grow up are you
from I'm from Fort Smith Arkansas
Arkansas and tell me about your family
yet both your parents growing up um I'm
adopted okay and my adoptive father
passed away from cancer and heart
disease and my mom is 80 okay and how
was your childhood um it was cool I had
six hold on five brothers and sisters
adopted all adopted a good childhood no
crazy
I'm always like hide my like child it'll
be like I'm talking about right now but
it was cool it's just a lot of like
what's it fighting and stuff sometimes
and yeah but like physical sexual abuse
a like that um my brother my older
brother molested me when I was like 14
hmm I think 13 or 14 maybe younger I
can't remember it definitely was like
the beginning of middle school so close
like middle school high school middle
school yeah and then he was molested by
his older brother he was gay so yeah
uh-huh and that was his excuse to do it
to me I guess and I eventually forgave
him he's a marine now so we kind of talk
good stuff
forgiveness was great yeah and they
apologized so many times I just finally
I was like it's okay I forgive them yeah
that's really nice yeah and where'd you
life go when you left home um I really
wanted to go to college really bad and I
graduated home school cuz I got kicked
out of every school I was a troublemaker
growing up like I got kicked out of
school so many times like no district
around my house would take me there like
they're like no like she can't come like
so I ended up going to like a
continuation school and then I got
kicked out of that and I did some school
after that and I got all A's and B's and
I was like I want to go to college so
bad and I didn't want to go to regular
college so I went to fashion school okay
chopped out of that really fast
it's just partying everyday working and
partying so so you're working currently
as like oh yeah how would you describe
this like I would say like a I don't say
it like high-end escort like are you an
escort or like you know better I usually
yeah I think I say I'm uh like a
entertainer
I get paid to entertain or like I'm a
sugar baby
at the end of the day it's all the same
thing how many years have you been doing
this since college she's gone yeah like
I love my mom and my family was living
off of like the check but you get for
being adopted and they're also um
elderly like she had her check too so
when I moved for college I couldn't take
the money it's like that's how my mom
pays her rent right so I really needed
to have a job and I think I borrowed
fifty dollars or hundred ollars from her
sister one time I felt really bad
because it was her fast but money I was
like no I'm
ever want to ask my mom for money again
or my sister or anyone so this girl my
roommate got me into it
actually this was still in Arkansas no I
moved to LA yeah yeah I moved to LA and
I went to school for like three months
and then I dropped out but like two of
the months one of the months I didn't
even go to class it was like and then I
just dropped out I'm not going back yeah
so because you're working on a I was
working like every day just to pay to
live in the student housing and art
school is more expensive to me than
normal College cuz you have to buy all
these like supplies with the assignment
see it like seven assignments coz I was
in seven classes full-time student and
then I didn't get hurt along with my
roommates cuz they were all like big and
scary and mean and I didn't hang out
with them so I was working you know and
they couldn't go with me so I was like
high-end they didn't like that and they
would always pick on me like try and
fight me so I just don't wanna go to
school anymore I was like over it
so you make good money doing this right
I've been on my own since I was 17
without any experiences of doing
anything my mom never let me out of the
house ever like you know I was
completely like just went to college
kind of like a virgin and um yeah I just
feel like I'm so good at what I do
because my first job was high-end
escorting but then I wanted to get a job
you know and I worked at guess and I
made like top seller of the month like
when I worked there like you know what I
mean oh wait this is [ __ ] like oh I
can make so much more money I'm wasting
my time I'm so pretty everyone thinks on
model let me just do it and then I saw
modeling for like playboy and like
getting into things like that and I
think it works out the high-end
escorting need pictures to get gig some
time over they overlapped quite a bit
you know so it was like fun I learned
about makeup and like dressing up I
actually enjoy it your clientele or they
treat you nicely you don't you
I mean everyone's been I think through
had they're like times or ever and I
definitely have had some crazy wild
stories and I feel like lately though
I've been I'm good but you're not
getting like a lot of a lot of the girls
that work Figaro for example or whatever
they do I know some girls that actually
like worked the streets I don't do that
but but down there you'll get guys
raping you and doing all kinds of
terrible things really you're at you're
not seeing that because you're at this
other level yeah not like that
yeah never I mean that you'll be in
casinos or yeah things like that I mean
I definitely had the GHB drug or
whatever you know but I don't remember
anything
II wouldn't remember anything have you
been arrested ever yes um not for being
a high-end escort but I Drive a lot of
nice fast cars all the time and I'm
always like really cute with like super
sounds cuz I modeled for like this car
shows and they gave me these sound
system so my car like it's really loud
and you're just super dope and fast and
I always get pulled over and I end up
going to jail cuz I've never had a
driver's license and then when I finally
got one like a year to go I got taken
away and I don't have one so I go to
jail sometimes for driving not
prostitution no just for driving so your
family knows you do this your mom um
yeah I mean yeah I told my mom I think
I've always told my mom what I do but
you know she didn't like it at first she
tried to talk me to go back into school
and whatever and like I didn't raise you
like this you're Christian it was kind
of bad like we weren't talking for a
minute but
but the way you speak about it I don't
get the feeling a this is a terrible
thing that you just have I think she
realized that I'm actually like really
good she saw me on TV a couple times for
modeling I have a store in Vegas make
the money stripping and then I am a
high-end escort and I look really cute
when I do it and I think all that you're
smiling and laughing and heavy it made
her feel like okay there cannot crying
telling these stories oh no but I've
cried and told her stories before but
not recently I did this line this is
doing this for a living ever get down oh
my god yeah it does only because I feel
like I just feel like um I really want
to like have a house with kids and you
know but I just feel like I'm not there
yet a more stable life I need to be more
stable I'm like more appropriate I don't
want to raise kids that way yeah how
much know you're living in it so
definitely would see something and I'm
just kids really like me the way I look
and they already like always asking me
like what I'm wearing they follow me
around you know I mean they talk about
me I just look if I had a kid like she's
gonna watch me and like see what I'm
doing and kind of hi walk whatever and
what she's gonna end up doing those
things I just wouldn't do that to
someone right now no yeah hey look your
customers are what kind of people what
kind of guys always older men usually
older they're probably married sometimes
married aldermen successful fun and
interesting
the sexual interactions you'll have are
typically normal and pretty pretty
standard or is it getting to like fits
into like yeah like I I think I'm
finally okay with doing those things but
in the beginning it was so hard like
what's the weirdest thing you've been
asked to do well the weirdest thing I've
been asked to do oh my god the weirdest
thing
I feel like the weirdest thing I've had
to do was have sex with this girl like
this guy asked me to [ __ ] her in the ass
was this chap on when I was doing it I
was so high that I like thought I was a
guy for a second and I was like stroking
the strap-on and I was like woah like
cuz I there's a mirror right there you
know and I'm just like totally goes into
it for a second and I'm like wait I'm
not a guy it was kind of fun interesting
I made a lot of money and he was
watching he was watching I guess he
wanted to prove his girlfriend was a
lesbian
oh there's a girlfriend that you were
having fun with and then like she ended
up committing suicide like not even like
weeks after I went over to his house it
was so weird I'm just like yeah I'm not
comfortable sometimes doing little jobs
like that not trying to hurt anyone and
drugs are part of the picture for you I
used to do drugs all drugs like anything
I've tried everything almost everything
um but I don't do drugs
cuz my mom does drugs and I just feel
like I don't want to be like my mom
you're it you're by logic my real
parents that's why I got taken away they
do drugs yeah
sell drugs and do drugs and I just
really didn't want to do that but I
smoked weed all the time I drink but
that's it but I used to like do coke
Molly um all that I've tried everything
yeah have you been in love before yeah I
do feel like I've been in love I'm
wondering yeah I'm wondering how this
lifestyle interferes I didn't realize I
was in love with someone until like I
got into this so it's thought it just
doesn't work out you know any means
that's why I'm still doing very very
difficult to have this lifestyle and be
in love so I'm really not focused on
like love right now I am just focus on
like like um companionship I guess like
you know like maybe like a friend or a
partner I could trust and hang out with
and like you know yeah
but I'm not like I'm not trying to have
kids right now or and hold are you I'm
25 Detroit on yeah
so you're still very young uh yeah I
think I'll probably be in this lifestyle
till I'm like 30 to be honest because I
love traveling I've been to like so many
countries and like I feel like guys love
paying for girls travel I'm like I can't
do that with the boyfriend I really
tried it and it's like miserable so your
your cousin your guy the guys that you
call customers will sometimes fly you to
all the time like they fly me places
they pay my bills they feed me they take
care of my dog they clean for me they
all that stuff bought me boobs you know
fix my car fine jewelry like my yachts
fun I think at first when I first
started I was scared like the first time
I had to go do it I was so scared
and then like I did it a few times I
start crying and I never did it again
for a minute look I did it again I just
always kept doing it again getting
normal jobs and doing again doing again
and now I didn't just like I've been
just doing it like everyone like loves
it - all my girlfriends and I do it
together like you know there you're
making it sound very appealing and I'm
just I like to get all these different
perspectives
what would advice are but words of
wisdom would you would you share with a
young girl who's seeing your video
interviewing going wow this doesn't seem
so bad don't do it don't be a high-end
escort but it's your only option and
you're already kind of in a situation
like that I would say get help like if
they have a lot of money can help you
why not ask first one hope and you don't
have to do it in it you know aggressive
way you could just do it in a nice
friendly way fun with females but like
you I feel like that's how I do it like
I do it in a very slick like sexy cute
way it just happen when it comes off
natural rather than it being like you
know in the middle and the men kind of
say carry me and you have fun
and no one gets hurt no one gets hurt
I'm always very careful and nice and
clean and my friends are safe like you
always you ever have something you
haven't had that experiences I've had a
couple bad experiences like where like I
told you to HB yeah and we know just
seeing pictures the next day of me and
like scratches and like little like
flashbacks and waking up telling someone
on me you know but not really knowing
what happened because I was locked out
things like that so I don't really have
that like super traumatic and I have
been like like not kidnapped girls would
say kidnapped but I have I got tricked
into being like living with the pimp and
his girlfriend cuz those girls like come
live in my pit house I was like oh my
god like I really want to live in a pit
house my ex dumped me like I'm on you
know I'm couchsurfing like why not so I
moved in and as soon as I moved in it
was like I got beat up the SIM card is
taken offense at that experience like
the phone numbers were all deleted I had
no buddies number but my mom I'm not
gonna tell my mom what happen like she's
80 usually I'm not gonna tell her she's
had a heart attack so I just uh end up
getting back to my ex he's the only
person the number I had and so even
though we broke up and I left him
because we broke up he kicked me out and
um I had to call him he was the only
number I had and the only person that
you know so it just crazy although
universe works but he actually answered
and he took me back but we only were to
get lived together for like a month and
we broke up again but he helped you out
in that situation yes it's a blessing
that he actually picked up the phone at
like 2:00 in the morning I was at the
strip club about mushy made me strip
make money instead I was making $1,000 a
day and like days or she wasn't even
making that much and she'd get so
jealous and pissed off and like she
thought I liked her pimp boyfriend which
I never even hooked up with him until
she made me so it's just like you know
she was tripping she's on a good one but
I ran away I ended up calling him I used
the taxi driver cuz she got sick one
morning I think she got pregnant or
something but she was like throwing up
and stuff and she's like you go to work
because she finally trusted me
I guess I was making so much money you
know I wasn't complaining you know you
know they mean I was there for like at
least a month or two and with that short
period of time you were bringing the
money and giving it to them oh yeah they
would take all my money and leave me
with like like a few ones in my wallet
and that'd be like you know and every
time I ate it's like with her every time
I [ __ ] someone she knew every time I was
at work she's like watching Inc she
works there
or she'd have people watching me it was
just so weird so yeah you had your own
stories of debauchery
I was so desperate and young and like
lonely that I just and I kind of
honestly I was curious I wanted to learn
how to make cuz I was being high-end
escort by myself I never was a stripper
I never was like going on those websites
where girls go on and doing any of that
and she kind of she brought me and
introduced me to all that and so I've
been since then I've been making at
least a thousand every day when I'm
working I think that's good money I
could make more modeling and like sell
like doing porn or something but that's
pretty good a lot of like that's just a
lot for me like I don't know if I really
want my pictures out there like that and
I did porn one time and I only made
$1,000 and the girl that it was for she
made like so much money you know naming
and just I don't like to feel that way
like kind of taking an advantage of in
that situation so I just would rather go
see someone real quick for a thousand
yeah nobody knows about it yeah you seem
you seem very happy with your life it
could be better I really want like a
nice you know estate auction or
something for 25 years old I think here
is it good you're doing pretty good
thank you
all Thanks very interesting perspective
on this life that you like yeah because
I think it's because I'm around older
people all the time that I feel like I
need to be like driving the Ferrari to
what I'm imagine I need to be like
pulling on the trim I've heard a wide
range of stories from the most tragic
you can imagine to to something like
yours which is one of the nicest most
pleasant less traumatic
stories I've heard thank you you still
have some stories well I'm just bent
there's so much things that I just feel
like this is the most appealing way for
me to live right now because I could
dance I could sing karaoke I could
massage I like to dress up I love
traveling I like flirting I like
drinking like smoking I like meeting
people I think your personality also is
a huge part of your success perhaps I
people tell me all the time I like I
make probably modest career is not for
every every girl probably not I've seen
some girls like not really into it but
I'm always into it yeah I try to make
the best of every situation
all right Oceana thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you good luck
with whatever you do from here thank you
Thanks hey was it lit you did great
you